et son équipe de 6 employés produisent
près de 4000 secondes par jour à son
usine de Montréal depuis le début de
l'année l'entrepreneur a perdu 22000
dollars en raison de la hausse du prix
de ces ingrédients le beurre a doublé
puis ça c'est sans préavis tout le temps
là on nous avertit pas le prix augmente
la facture suivante par exemple 25 kg de
beurre lui coûte maintenant 295 dollars
au lieu de 153$ en 2021 une hausse de
93%. et pour un sac de farine c'est 25
dollars plutôt que 18 dollars 50 soit un
bon de 35%
la livraison le transport tous ceux et
comme
c'est sans fin
pour à peu près tout et rien et je pense
que c'est comme une réaction en chaîne
et pour garder la tête hors de l'eau le
propriétaire a fait le choix de vendre
ses scones en paquet de 4 plutôt qu'en
paquet de 6 au même prix soit 9 dollars
99 une entente avec les principales
bannières en alimentation l’oblige à
conserver son prix de vente initial peu
importe l'évolution de ses coups de
production pour changer un prix de
produit en épicerie le producteur
fait un long chemin de croix avec les
les différentes bannières c'est la
négociation c'est souvent refusé après
chaque boîte de ce compte vendu le
propriétaire doit verser 4 dollars 50 à
l'épicier il ne lui reste en moyenne que
5 dollars 15
dormais la nuit souvent mais je fais
encore là on met la littéralement la
main à la porte pour accélérer la
production pour s'assurer que le produit
a la même qualité jour après jour
malgré les prix des aliments qui
continuent de grimper Luke Sénéchal
continue de s'accrocher et de voir grand
en servant un client à la fois ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal